the daily today was talking about
childhood obesity and how's the epidemic
in in the country apparently like
doctors are now literally telling
children that they should get bariatric
surgery which is wild it's like my dad
got it my brother got it it's cash
bypass they like cut your stomach
basically kids yeah they're just
straight up like nope this is like doing
that apparently doctors are now very
aggressively trying to like early on
immediately uh suggest it's usually seen
as like our last resort which is why I
thought it was strange that they're like
immediately hitting that button for well
I think in the cases of like extreme
obesity of kids when like it's really
crazy I think like it's like 90 morbidly
obese for life you know how we have a
concept of like oh that's just baby fat
like that's not it that's what doctors
were basically saying like nope that's
not baby fat it doesn't go away you're
just like OB your child is obese and
he's going to be an obese adult and it's
also one in five it says around 55 of
obese children go on to be obese in
adolescence around 80 of abuse
adolescence will be obese adults